are you working out regularly because it
seems like you are are you what kind of
exercise do you do um you know i've
always worked out that's the truth and
i've always eaten healthy because i love
food so i work out so that i can keep
eating i mean that's the truth i i do
love to go and eat every day um unlike a
lot of people in hollywood um
i don't skip food um but anyways i you
know what it is and this is not a plug
for anything there's a thing called the
up bracelet you like it they have the
nike fit or whatever those things are
yeah so i always do my 10 000 steps
every day and i log in what i do and all
my girlfriends are on it and so you know
it's it's a very fun little system to
keep did you do this walk around the
neighborhood are you a treadmill person
treadmill treasure treadmill and well
you've seen me here we're on the warner
brothers lot yeah and um and i can't
really go most places because of
paparazzi issues so i take my stroller
and wyatt and i go walking around the
warner brothers lot and we go and have
picnics over by the fake lake that they
have here for true boy
ah the old the old romantic fake lake
from true blood
and there's a farmer's market here so i
go to the farmer's market every other
wednesday it's a nice little world we
have here but i'm curious if you do the
thing i do which i'll get on the
treadmill and i'll just watch tv that i
normally wouldn't watch oh i do that all
the time i don't know if you do it oh i
do it and i get judged for it um i do
and it's okay yeah so i'm on the
treadmill and then i have the little
like fisher price little rocker i put
wyatt in there
and then um and i watch bear with me
everybody and do not judge the real
housewives of beverly hills now here's
the thing about the show do you ever
watch it i have watched that show yes
these women are
horrible they're
like don't you say that
mila those are my
friends if that was the case
i would not be your friend
um that show is the worst show on
television next to true tori which is
also true tori i don't even know what
that is i know that's the problem you
should know what it is
and true what is true tori
anyone before anybody nope of course i'm
gonna guess no shut up you don't lie all
right no i'm gonna i'm gonna guess
it's tori spelling's reality show yes it
was done in like real time while the
tabloids were talking about the stuff
that was happening in her life yeah she
had this reality show it made me so
uncomfortable
it was horrible it they [ __ ] children on
the show and a poor thing i just wanted
to be like you need help you need to get
just get these cameras out and it made
me so uncomfortable i actually stopped
watching the show wait wait that's so
real
but you were on it you're on a treadmill
watching shows that you actively hate
true and then and then actually judges
me for it fully judges me
will come into the room 100 he's like
hey you're working out i was like yeah
and they'll be like oh i can't believe
you
and then you just get sucked into it
because it's like cat fights happen
weaves are being chucked to places like
the women look like they just got beat
by like a drag queen like
amazing it is one of the greatest things
on television so you're saying it's
horrifying but you watch it but you get
in shape at the same time so it's a lot
of yeah it's it keeps me going right
yeah i love it it's called hate watching
we get so many viewers that way